before we start I want to thank Elsword
for being kind enough to sponsor this
video I actually sir playing Elsword
several months ago and I truly enjoy
playing it it is a free-to-play MMORPG
that puts you into an anime inspired
world where you can pick from many
unique playable characters and let loose
on enemies or other players using fast
paced sword combos mere magic combos and
so much more in fact
Elsword has just introduced a brand new
playable character called lady a cute
pink haired girl with very sharp teeth
and extremely cool meer based powers she
has mirror attacks like goes from black
clover and is as cute as his little
sister Marie actually named my character
girl go levy has a variety of cool
attacks and choose from so that made the
playing experience so much fun I really
had a great time discovering all her
skills and powers check it out for
yourself it's really a fun anime
inspired adventure that would definitely
recommend to my friends the link is in
the description and it's totally free to
download
[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today I'm going to be ranking
every black Bowl from weakest to
strongest if you love black clover and
want to see more black clover videos in
the future make sure to smash that like
button to let me know also let me know
what video you would like to see next in
the comments and like other people's
requests that you agree with since that
is often how I choose what video to make
next if you're new make sure to smash
that subscribe button and bring that
magic YouTube Bell if you want Finn Robb
to use his magic to teleport new videos
straight to you Before we jump into the
rankings I want to say that this list is
my opinion although I will be using
evidence from the series to organize my
rankings this list is also biased
towards powerful attack magic as opposed
to support magic which can aid one's
allies some people on this list as we'll
see have insanely useful magic that when
used in combination with another
person's magic can be extremely useful
in fact all magic on this list can be
extremely useful in certain situations
but we are focusing on how strong the
fighters are without the help of their
allies in battle
also there is spoiler magic ahead you've
been warned
and if you want to get a more detailed
breakdown on any one of these black
bowls you can check out my all black
bowl members and their powers explained
video now without further ado let's jump
into it first off we have gray as with
most characters I'm mentioning earlier
on grey has extremely useful magic
called transformation magic that can
come in handy when she can use it in
combination with teammates she can
transform herself to look like one of
her teammates thereby she can catch the
opponent off guard she can also convert
people's magic into another type of
magic so when fighting with someone she
can convert magic so that her teammates
magic is super effective against their
opponents magic in the black lower world
magic types play a very important role
making Gray's power a great asset for
the black bowls
however on her own gray would have
trouble defeating her opponents she has
no significant offensive attacks to
speak of so far so she would constantly
be on the defensive it also doesn't help
that she is extremely shy and for that
reason she would have trouble focusing
if she
had to transform back to her true form
for these reasons I have to put gray on
the bottom of the list next up we have
the lady loving Finn role in his spatial
magic then role knows he's not strong on
his own which is why he said to himself
I don't have to become the strongest
I'll make the black bull's the strongest
squad and quote he knows that he shines
in helping his squad and along with
Vanessa he helped us to fight against
meadow in doing so they fared better
than any one of them could have done
alone at the time the only offensive
move he's used this fallen angel
flapping this spell has a big drawback
in that it is slow but it does follow
the target the spatial magic is launched
at the opponent and when it comes to
contact with the opponent they are
forcibly teleported to a location of the
users choosing as long as the user has
been there at one point
thus best-case scenario the slow spell
might hit the opponent and send them far
away a spell like this may be pretty
useful if FINRA can transport the person
into an inescapable prison room or above
a volcano but so far we have only seen
him transport someone into the Blackwell
washroom although this spell can
potentially be useful in battle a fast
and powerful opponent would likely be
able to defeat FINRA before the attack
and make contact with them general can
use his portals to swallow up enemy
attacks and potentially have them
teleported back to the opponents in
short although he's excellent assisting
the black bulls in battle he has not
accomplished enough on his own which is
why I can't place him any higher on this
list following Finn raw we got Vanessa
with her thread magic Vanessa is able to
use the red thread of fate which
manifests as a red cat that is able to
change destiny this magic is opie but as
the witch Queen pointed out in addition
to being unavoidable the cat is also
harmless as a result this spell is great
when you have teammates around so you
can protect them from harm and they can
focus on attacking the opponent however
to spell itself will be able to take the
opponent out of commission Vanessa
nevertheless has other means that she
can use to defeat an opponent when the
black bulls are in the underwater temple
before vetto shows up fin Rollins trying
to avoid being seen by anyone and
running away from any opponents he sees
while Vanessa is seen using the thread
magic to easily trap an opponent all by
herself
her thread magic can work like a large
spider web allowing her to catch
opponents like flies
thus she has used her magic to
single-handedly defeated us in the past
but like the other people already
mentioned she really shines when it
comes to supporting her teammates and
for that reason she did not rank higher
on this list next we have Gordon and his
poison magic now we are getting to
characters that have more offensive
spells gory can't summon badges are boys
and and they're actually strong enough
to chew through a magically reinforced
corpse Sally the mad scientist cannot
help but remark and how strong Gordon's
poison magic is it is suggested that
Gordon usually holds back when he's
fighting against living people because
after attacking the corpse she says and
I quote if you aren't alive I'll use my
magic as much as I like and both Gouri
can also use a kind of poison kamehameha
and also send a cloud of poison at the
enemy just like in Pokemon Gordon's
poison is super effective against grass
or plant type magic so it's nice when
gray is there to convert the enemies
spell like when she turned Sally's Kjell
salamander into plant magic allowing
Gordon to destroy it with his poison
cloud while Goren's personality tends to
hold him back our next contestant has an
explosive personality which definitely
doesn't hold him back from endangering
the lives of his targets which is why I
had to place him ahead on this list and
if you haven't guessed that I'm
referring to the man Lee Magna and his
fire magic there's no surprise a Magna
beat out gourd on this list Magna has
many more offensive attacks than Gordon
and fights more often - which suggests
that he has more fighting experience not
to mention he is in competition with his
best friend Luck who is insanely strong
so this pushes magnet to train even
harder
most of magnet attacks deal with
throwing balls of fire at the opponent
he can set the fireballs to explode
after a period of time so that they can
harm the opponent even if they miss he
also has tricky shots which make his
fireballs harder to dodge and he can
make his fireballs larger magma helps
Austin beat Grice and he even comes up
with the plan to beat him showing that
he can't come up with good strategies in
battle in the underwater temple magma is
able to easily defeat one of the priests
by himself magma is not an exceptional
talented fighter when compared to some
of the other black bulls and he wasn't
chosen to be a royal knight but he's no
slouch and because of his manly spirit
and the fact that hasta and Luck are
there to inspire him Magda will no doubt
keep getting stronger while some people
like Gordon don't seem to care about
competing and trying to be stronger than
their teammates next up we have Ghosh
and his mere magic Ghosh is a strong
fighter and like magnet he is able to
easily defeat LAN the priest in the
underwater temple on his own on top of
already having more magic than magnet to
begin with he also has the mere magic
tool in his eye that can accumulate
magic and make his spell stronger he can
create copies of himself all of which
surround an enemy target and use mirrors
to reflect light beams that in theory
destroy whatever is in between them he
can also make a mirror manifest in a
specific location and teleport in front
of it we do not know the range of this
ability but he used it to quickly get in
front of Yami during the fight against
Patri who also calls himself licked at
the time as we saw gauche can summon a
giant mirror and reflect Patras light
magic effectively but there are also
magic types that he's weak against like
gel magic it's worth mentioning that
gauche is a smartest black bull a fact
that would help him come up with
effective strategies during a fight
overall gauche is strong but I believe
that the following black bulls are even
stronger following gauche we have Henry
with his recombination magic which lets
him turned the black bull base into a
mecha that he can control I said earlier
in this list I'm mainly focusing on how
strong these characters are on their own
in Henry's case I am also thinking about
how he would fight without the
assistance of his allies in battle but
it should be noted that he gets his
magic power that he would use in a fight
from the black bowl members so for the
sake of this list we are assuming that
he already absorbed a large amount of
mana from his teammates before the
hypothetical fight begins in his black
bull Mecca
Henry is very powerful the giant bull
can use a drill like punch as well as a
rocket punch that says the mecca's fists
flying at the enemy only to return after
impact
in addition in Chapter 188 of the manga
Henry explains that when he exits the
Blackwell base his loop of magic
absorption is broken so instead of
siphoning off a bit of magic from a lot
of people he can directly absorb all the
magic from one person so that person's
magic would run out a lot quicker than
usual so it gets an opponent he can exit
the house if he needs to and try to
drain the opponent's mana when gauche
gray and Gordon all of whose names start
with G incidentally are losing to na
DiSpirito in his number zero michael
says all corpse henry comes to the
rescue
this corpse is overwhelmingly powerful
since it was made from two different
corpses because of this the corpse can
use two different magical elements and
not only that but the previous corpses
that were used to make him came from two
former magic knight captains so this is
an insanely powerful opponent and yet in
his black bull Mecca
Henry has no problem taking him out
which shows just how strong he is
next up we have Zora and his ashe and
trap magic Sora has quite the list of
accomplishments he manages to defeat lug
nerd a vice captain of the purple orcas
before he borrows the vice captain's
identity for the Royal Knight selection
exam in the exam in one round he manages
to take out three magic knight opponents
with his trap magic at once
he helps awesome make sure that the
vice-captain Golden Dawn languorous Finn
Rahl's insanely talented brother doesn't
beat them it even looked like they would
win but it ended up being a tie as both
crystals fell apart at the same time
Zora because of his skill was selected
to be a royal Knight despite being a
commoner his traps can actually increase
the power of the opponent's magic attack
by two or even more Fausta's around and
then Sora can send the attack no matter
how powerful back at the target Zora and
hasta use Sora's trap magic to help
rescue metal Leona from five Opie elves
including Raya and an elf possessed rail
not only can Zora defend against
extremely powerful attacks he can send
them back even stronger
combine that with this cleverness and
insight and you can see why I had to put
him so high on this
next up we have the tiny but powerful
charm II and her cotton magic the issue
with ranking Charmy is we know she's
strong but we don't know how strong
exactly she can summon a giant brand
that can punch out powerful opponents
the attack easily defeating Katherine
who was giving the talented you know
trouble in a vine mage who had trapped
both gray and gauche after she saves
them Co she even says and I quote I hate
to admit it but she's got real strong
attack power and quote so when she's
fought she's been able to effortlessly
defeat her opponents because she thought
they were trying to steal her food but
we've never seen charming get challenged
and pushed to her limit by a really
strong opponent so we don't know how far
her strength goes from what we've seen I
can justify putting her this high on the
list however I can't put her any higher
until we get a better sense of her
strength following Charming we have the
electrifying Luck voltea aka the cheery
Berserker luck possesses lightning magic
he wraps himself in lightning which
increases his speed and attack power
luck was always presented as a strong
character in fact he's obsessed with
fighting strong opponents which is
definitely the attitude that a strong
character would adopt you wouldn't see
Yamcha getting excited to fight against
beetles for instance but the strong Goku
would get excited about the idea
furthermore Lux strength is shown in his
backstory too as a young kid he beat a
noble and as his mother explains and I
quote almost nobody beats a noble here's
something special and quote Lotus who is
almost as talented at fighting as he is
running away
also has to admit that luck is tough
when he sees his power when metal fights
him he also lets luck know that he has
good speed and sharp senses of course in
the end even with Magnus help luck was
no match for vetto at the time however
he's gotten significantly stronger since
that point after the elf that possessed
his body left his body luck explains
that his body still remembers how the
elf used his mana so he can recreate
that strong form that the elf used when
he was in his body
in short luck was talented to begin with
and he's growing stronger fast if Magna
really hopes to catch up with him all
I can do is wish him good luck next we
have Noel Silva yes the girl who
couldn't even properly use her magic in
the beginning however she's improved
more than even Luck has since the
beginning of the series
unlike Sakura Naruto and you know how
much I love bringing up Sakura Noel is
remaining extremely strong and relevant
even when compared to the main character
who is Austen in this case while luck
and Magnus combined attack couldn't even
scratch vetto no Wells attack sea
dragons roar was able to take off that
hose right arm later the same attack
overpowered the fire spirit salamander
albeit the water-based attack does have
an elemental advantage you might be
thinking that luck has gotten stronger
since the fight against meadow since
he's got a shiny new form and as a
result he might be stronger than a while
however the truth is Noel has
drastically improved since that fight -
and she also has a new form her spell
Valkyrie armor probably one of my
favorite spells it's not my favorite
surrounds her body with an Armour of
water and equips her with a spinning
Lance that can drill through other
spells this spell allows her to defeat
the strongest elf in the area who was
able to take no Zell the captain of the
Silver Eagle squad out of commission in
my view with this spell she has for the
time being surpass luck and strength
Noel also has some noteworthy statistics
she got a perfect 5 out of 5 in magic
amount which makes sense and she is a
noble and a 5 out of 5 in her customized
category which is growth so we can
definitely expect her strength to keep
on growing Menno leona actually sees
Noelle's initial crude magic control as
a positive thing she explains that
Noelle's mother was extremely strong and
trained meadow Leona herself
Mero Leona says that she herself was
undefeated on the battlefield but didn't
manage to beat Noelle's mother hace
Silva even once even though she had the
elemental advantage since her fire was
super effective against RCA's mercury
Noelle's mom had sophisticated and
dignified control of her magic while
Noel according to Meadow Leona is clumsy
and hard to watch but many old Iona
believes that because no
well didn't start out super talented and
had to work hard to get stronger she
will even surpass her mother and
strength this is a huge statement since
meadow Leona is one of the strongest
characters in the series and she was
unable to beat ICA Silva so she's saying
that Noelle will even surpass her the
undefeated lioness herself I could not
imagine a bigger compliment and it goes
to show just how much potential Noelle
has following the well we have Austin
the magic less Boy Wonder himself also
has a lot of things going for him he is
the physically strongest character in
the series after the number one guy on
this list his swords are excellent for
battle they allow him to cut through and
deflect magic attacks the diamond Waller
sword can borrow magic from other people
which can increase the range of his
attacks a drawback that auste had for a
while was the fact that he needed help
from others because he could not fly or
move quick enough to hit some opponents
with his sword as a result he needed to
rely on people like Finn raw and Vanessa
for help however that changed when he
unlocked his own new form the black
hasta form man with all these new forms
popping up I hope we see Yami get one
too anyways black hasta is insanely fast
and he can fly as well allowing him to
quickly close the distance between
himself and his opponent hasta beat la
dross in his black hasta form even
though this was Londres at his strongest
after he had absorbed the fire speared
salamander although hasta asked Magda
and Vanessa to back him up when he was
fighting the elf that had possessed love
it must be kept in mind that hasta had
to hold back to an extent because he did
not want to kill a lot while the elf
could go all out because of that it made
sense that all three should work
together to try and save luck as fast as
possible so for all these reasons I
decided to put Auslan 2nd place however
I do believe that luck in the well are
not far behind for the time being
lastly we have the myth the legend
himself Yami the captain of the black
bulls since the beginning of the series
Yami was one of the strongest characters
he scored a perfect 5 out of 5 in magic
amount not to mention he is physically
the strongest character in the entire
series
he possesses dark magic and he managed
to overcome its slowness by channeling
it into a katana he can send slashes of
dark magic flying at his opponents at
quick speeds since the series started
Yami has also learned one of the most
opie magic attacks in the series of
course I'm referring to dark cloak
dimensions slash which can get this
slice through dimensions notably it can
cut through spatial magic as well even
before he learned a spell he was able to
fight against Patri and his opie like
magic without being defeated now that he
knows this move chances are he could
defeat Patri which is likely why Patri
fled the last time he saw Yami Yami is
stronger than he's ever been and he'll
only get stronger in the data book
Yami's customized category was limit
surpassing and he got a perfect 5 out of
5 in that his ability to surpass his
limits when he has no other choice
should not be overlooked when we're
talking about how strong this guy is
ironically this dark magic user even
shines among the magic knight captains
in short there's a reason that Yami is
the captain he stands on top of the
black bull totem pole and that is it for
today's video if you want more details
about any one of the black poles make
sure to check out my video all members
of the black bulls and their powers
explain where I spent a ton of time
explaining each one of them thank you so
much for watching if you liked the video
make sure to smash that like month let
me know if you have enjoyed the black
balls of youtube by hitting that
subscribe button and bringing that magic
youtube bell remember to scream like aa
star while you're doing it leave
suggestions for future videos you are
burning up to see in the comments on a
slide know we have yet to see the vice
captain of the black bull squad but I
can't see him being stronger than Yami
although as with every other time Tama
does seem to keep something cloud in
mystery I'm sure that the vice-captain
will be worth the wait
let me know how you think the
vice-captain would rank on this list
with the vice-captain stand a chance
against hasta and let me know where you
think the vice-captain has been all this
time anyways remember to grow never give
up and kill your limits today and every
other day and until next time see you
space cowboy
[Music]
you